nous avions l'habitude de les voir se
rassembler pour discuter avec les
professeurs et autres intervenants en
vue de leur orientation future
les étudiants auront cette année accès à
des salons virtuels développé pour les
accompagner le mieux possible en temps
on se connecte on arrive dans un rôle
différent des passes avec différents
lieux des changes
et puis on a construit de façon à ce
qu'on puisse malgré tout mettre en place
ce qui importe où n en fait c'est d
interaction directe avec les différents
intervenants parmi les principaux enjeux
cette année parcours sup
plusieurs des neuf conférences
organisées par le média l'étudiant sont
dédiés à la plateforme d'orientation
post bac
c'est vraiment l'occasion pour ces
jeunes qui se posent des questions sur
cette procédure et on sait à quel point
ça peut être compliqué en cette période
de crise sanitaire et à quel point déjà
d'ordinaire ça plaide un petit peu
anxiogène
les conférences seront accessibles en
replay jusqu'au 21 février afin que
chacun puisse prendre le temps de se
renseigner un nouveau format qui
pourrait être utilisé en complément du
salon physique dès l'année prochaine